[Musique]
je ne savais pas qu'un jour je finirai
par vaincre ma peur du vide ma peur du
vertige je m'étais bien gardé ce matin
là de dire à mon équipe que j'allais
peut-être pas osé escalade et avec eux
la pyramide de khéops et cette escalade
qu'on a réalisé en janvier 2010 est en
fait elle avait pour but d'examiner une
zone dans laquelle la mission scan
pyramide avait réalisé une première
découverte une petite cavité dans cet
art est nord-est l'arête par laquelle on
est en train de passer alors
effectivement après le premier petit
vide qu'on avait découvert en 2016 a
annoncé en 2016 on savait à ce moment au
moment où on grimpe et on savait qu'on
avait quelque chose de plus important ce
qu'on a baptisé après le pic voight mais
en avait encore besoin de mesures on
avait besoin que les équipes en fait
nous confirme en fait les résultats que
l'on avait et c'est ainsi que le 2
novembre 2017
on a publié dans la revue nature ce qui
est assez rare en égyptologie la
découverte en fait telle annonce en fait
d'un vide inconnu dans la pyramide de
khéops qu'on a baptisée le big boy des
qui était notre troisième découverte et
de nombreux médias en fait on qualifier
cette découverte de l'une des
découvertes les plus importantes de
l'année de l'année 2010 est cool aux
scientifiques discovery zooey les
événements scientifiques qui ont marqué
l'année 2017 et j'avoue que j'étais moi
même le premier surpris puisque dans les
autres événements scientifiques de
l'année 2010 est il y avait l'invention
de nanomachines pour caen bat combattre
les cellules cancéreuses ou bien sûr là
la découverte des ondes des ondes
gravitationnelles
pendant des années on a sauté dans le
vide mais c'étaient des vides virtuel
l'objectif en fait de l'équipe que je
dirige était d'utiliser les techniques
de réalité virtuelle et techniques de
simulation chez dassault systèmes pour
tester des idées qu'ils pouvaient être
les plus les plus folles
c'est ainsi qu'on a par exemple
collaborer et on a été les pionniers à
mélanger réalité virtuelle et danse
contemporaine avec
la danseuse pietragalla et donc la
question souvent composent et que vous
devez vous poser c'est mémé mais
finalement à quoi ça sert de chercher de
chercher des vides et en quoi consiste
finalement une démarche une démarche
d'innovation
c'est super simple en fait démarche
d'innovation quand on a des
scientifiques des ingénieurs dans son
équipe il suffit simplement de les
reconnecter à leur rêve d'enfant à leur
imaginaire d'enfant un ingénieur un
scientifique c'est ni prix ni moi
quelqu'un qui a vu des films de science
fiction star trek la téléportation le
téléphone mobile et qui décide un jour
grâce à ses compétences et à grâce à
toutes les connaissances qu'il a
acquises et bien un moment donné de les
amener à la réalité les transformer en
réalité et donc tous ces mythes et tous
ces imaginaires sont extrêmement
importants et c'est pour ça que la
machine à imaginer aujourd'hui est clé
pour notre société
il faut à nouveau à nouveau rêver de cet
imaginaire on décide d'un ensemble sans
forcément se connaître à plusieurs est
bien de faire équipe de mener en fait
des défis par rapport à ses rêves
collectifs qu'on met en marche la
machine de la collaboration
interdisciplinaire et souvent ce qu'on
oublie c'est que le plus important dans
cette démarche c'est l'aventuré humaine
céléos et des basses et des engueulades
c'est les crises et ça on fait souvent
l'impasse en fait aujourd'hui sur
l'importance de ce ciment émotionnelle
qui fait que l'on peut avancer dans ce
type de davanture et puis ensuite les
innovations nes et puis peut-être
qu'elle rayonne et puis et puis c'est
ainsi qu'on avance et donc tenter de
résoudre en fait collectivement le
mystère de la pyramide c'est affirmer
aujourd'hui bacon que l'impossible est
possible puisque aujourd'hui quatre
mille cinq cents ans après la
construction de ce monument
on sait toujours pas comment il a été
construit mais je vous parlais
d'imaginaire et je suis sûr que le
premier imaginaire auquel vous renvoie
aujourd'hui la pyramide de khéops ou
l'egypte eh bien vous auriez aimé que je
trouve plutôt un plein plutôt qu'un vide
et donc malheureusement pour l'instant
la seule chose que l'on peut dire c'est
que c'est un vide qui a une certaine
taille au dessus de la grande galerie et
en parlant d' imaginaires je vous
présente sébastien procureur qui est
physicien en physique des hautes
énergies au cea qui fait partie de la
mission
après un an de mission sa maman a
retrouvé une bande dessinée en fait d'un
lapin célèbre d'une boîte de céréales
dans laquelle le lapin mais des lunettes
pour voir à travers la matière etc
que fait aujourd'hui sébastien et bien y
créer des instruments de biographies qui
permettent de voir à travers la matière
est ce que le lapin de la boîte de
céréales a influencé l'imaginaire de
sébastien je ne sais pas mais en tout
cas je pense que ça avoue un rôle dans
son dans son inconscient et c'est pour
ça que je vous disais que les ingénieurs
sont avant tout de grands enfants qui
ont cette capacité à se reconnecter à
leur rêve de gamin alors qu'est ce qu'on
sait aujourd'hui de cette pyramide de
khéops tout ce que l'on sait depuis
l'app yade sur la pyramide en fait date
du calife al mamoun en l'an 800 thons
fait qu'ils décident de monter une
expédition il est à la recherche du
trésor de khéops et puis il envoie toute
une équipe en fait qui va percer un
couloir au centre de la face nord de la
pyramide et pendant des mois et des mois
en fait ils vont progresser dans la
pyramide jusqu'à trouver toute la
structure interne en fait deux sets de 7
de cette pyramide
donc là on accueille obs ouvrons khéops
et donc on voit tout en bas une chambre
souterraine des couloirs
au milieu la chambre de la reine plus
haut la chambre du roy et bien tout ça
était découvert en fait par al mamoun au
moyen-âge et si on se projette un petit
peu en arrière on peut imaginer qu'on
ait un mercredi
ja doit être le conseil des vizirs dans
le même moule il devrait être furieux en
fait d'avoir investi autant moyen
pendant des mois et des mois à coude
instrument optique qui arrêtait pas de
casser à coups de feu de vinaigre pour
avancer péniblement en fait dans cette
pyramide et lui malheureusement au
moyen-âge ne pouvait pas se douter en
fait que cette découverte qu'il avait
fait et les vides qu'il avait découvert
en fait lancerait un truc qui s'appelle
l'industrie du tourisme et dont l'egypte
fait partie des icônes en fait de cette
de cette industrie et aujourd'hui on
peut parler d'un retour sur
investissement a à peu près dix siècles
et aujourd'hui les touristes continuent
inlassablement à emprunter ce tunnel que
vous avez devant vous ce tout petit
tunnel qui permet ensuite d'accéder de
visiter les vides qui avait découvert al
mamoun mais pour moi fait le principal
trésors de cette pyramide c'est le
mystère en fait de sa construction
et tout ça ça donne lieu aux théories
les plus farfelues dans lesquels on va
invoquer les atlantes dans laquelle on
va inventer invoqué les extraterrestres
et pourtant parce qu'on imagine que les
égyptiens de l'époque était une sorte de
grand enfant fait qu'il n'avait pas
même capacité que nous et parce qu'ils
n'avaient ni le faire ni la roue ni
twitter et pas dé l'homme mais ce qu'à
l'époque il était incapable de faire ça
alors on préfère invoquer les forces
surnaturelles et malheureusement c'est
ce qui se répand à vitesse grand v sur
les réseaux sans doute pour combler des
vides existentielle et d'autres types
d'obscurantisme dont on souffre
aujourd'hui
et donc quand on a lancé cette mission
c'était avant tout un exercice de style
pour réhabiliter en fait la rationalité
c'est à dire ces gens là étaient
capables de le faire il ya 4500 ans
qu'est ce que notre propre civilisation
sera capable de laisser dans 4500 la
pyramide nous renvoie en fait à nos
propres contradictions propres
contradictions de nos civilisations et
avant d'aller invoqué les
extraterrestres ou les dispositifs anti
gravité et si on nous remettre en fait
dans les pas de c2c de ces égyptiens et
donc en quoi consiste le mystère de la
construction de la pyramide
alors c'est plus grands monuments
pendant de l'humanité pendant plusieurs
millénaires il faut bien sûr résoudre le
problème du volume comment faire un
volume qui va monter jusqu'à 146 mètres
de haut mais aussi comprendre comment
cette chambre du roy en fait qui se
trouve au coeur de la pyramide a été
construite c'est le vrai mystère de la
pyramide c'est la chambre du roi car
elle a envoyé un plafond plein c'est la
première fois que les égyptiens font en
architecture un plafond plat au coeur
d'une structure et ils vont devoir
mettre des poutres de granit qui vont
faire jusqu'à plus de 60 tonnes vous
avez une vue de coupe de la pyramide et
puis tout en haut des chevrons en fait
qui protègent cette cette chambre de la
masse qui se trouve au dessus et c'est
aussi la première fois dans l'histoire
des pyramides qu'on utilise des chevrons
donc le vrai mystère de la construction
c'est la résolution du mystère de la
chambre du roi non pas pour y trouver
des trésors mais pour comprendre en fait
comment cet effet et comment nous mêmes
nous pouvons nous projeter dans l'avenir
et si on remonte quelques 3 3 millénaire
avant al mamoun on peut imaginer aussi
kheops lançant un défi en fait à et miou
l'architecte en chef lançant un défi à
en kf son vizir et lui dire je veux je
veux la plus haute
je veux la plus grande j'ai fait la
review du projet franchement les
chambres en encorbellement comme papa
j'en veux pas
il faut quelque chose au coeur de la
pyramide je veux pas un truc sous la
terre je veux pas un truc haut niveau au
niveau du sol
et puis ils ont dû lui répondre enfin
majesté vous phare on vous dit vous n'y
pensez pas on n'a jamais fait il va
falloir aller chercher à 900 km des
poutres qu'elle arrive en temps et en
heure sur le chantier au moment où on
sera à 43 mètres de hauteur au niveau
supply chain on a fait on n'a jamais
fait ça m'est égal
moi je veux un changement de paradigme
je veux un break through une rupture
l'intendance suivra et c'est ainsi en
fait que cette pyramide a fini par avoir
lieu et quand kef et mulhouse ont dû
résoudre des problèmes et il faut qu'on
comprenne comment ils ont résolu ses
problèmes et on trouve en dévidant la
pyramide gaza peut permettre de faire
avancer en fait sur la connaissance et
au niveau reporting les égyptiens était
super fort je vous présente pierre
talent et qui a publié en 2012 en fait
la découverte des papilles riz de merrer
donc sont les plus anciens papy relie
connues à ce jour et en fait c'était le
journal de bord du contremaître merrer
contemporain du chantier de la
construction qui encadraient une équipe
deux constructeurs de la pyramide et nos
fichiers excel n'ont absolument rien à
envier au tableau de bord quotidien que
tenait merrer la question en revanche
que ça peut poser c'est quel fichier
excel notre propre civilisation stockés
dans le vide pardon je voulais dire dans
le cloud nous survivra 4500 ans et c'est
pour ça que je vous dis que la pyramide
nous renvoie à beaucoup de questions par
rapport à notre propre civilisation et
pour construire une pyramide comme ça il
fallait une sacrée dose de spiritualité
il fallait sacré connaissance il fallait
deux sacrés compétences pour lancer ce
défi à d'éternité et qui a permis à
c'est à cet état 2 2 est bien de se
dépasser et et et de construire en fait
cette montagne de pierre et nous à
petite échelle cannes pyramide on s'est
dit que si on voulait apporter notre
pierre à l'édifice pour la compréhension
de cette de la pyramide de khéops il
fallait se replonger dans le passé et
tirer des leçons du passé et au xviiie
siècle quand napoléon en fait
lançon d'expédition son expédition en
egypte l'expédition qui était avant tout
militaire il a aussi l'idée d'embarquer
avec lui des artistes des ingénieurs des
scientifiques qui vont se pencher sur le
mystère de cette civilisation qui vont
documenter leur périple à l'époque on ne
sait pas encore lire les hiéroglyphes on
sait que cette civilisation est
extrêmement mystérieuse en fait
champollion
déchiffrer les hiéroglyphes ça donne
naissance en fait à l'égyptologie à
l'egypte oman ya à l'egypte au feeling
et aujourd'hui encore je pense a par
exemple un assassin's creed qui est
sorti il n'y a pas très longtemps tout
cet imaginaire a été nourrie et ça
contribue en fait au succès aussi des
industries créatives et d industrie du
jeu vidéo par exemple
et donc depuis la machine à fantasmes
fonctionne et ce qu'on a retenu en fait
de cette mission c'est qu'il fallait
qu'on monte une équipe vierge en fait de
tout a priori par rapport à la pyramide
et c'est pour ça on nous l'a reproché un
petit peu au début qu'on n'a pas intégré
d'égyptologues on voulait déjà en fait
sans enjeu par rapport à ceux à ce défi
donc des artistes des scientifiques des
ingénieurs dans différents domaines de
discipline donc on a des vous présente
une partie de l'équipe on à nicolas
godin le cofondateur du groupe de
musique r françois skelton l'auteur de
bandes dessinées les gens du cea de
nagoya du k1 k2 des canadiens des
japonais bien sûr des égyptiens avec la
faculté du caire j'en doute façon on
n'est pas égyptologue on n'a rien à
perdre essayons d'apporter quelque chose
et voyons ce qu'on peut faire
la fiction précède souvent la réalité et
françoise clayton qui fait partie de
l'équipe est en train d'écrire le vin de
dessiner le volume 3 du mystère de la
grande pyramide puis tout a rejoint en
fait cette cette aventure et il se
trouve que j'ai réalisé il ya peu en
fait que jacob savez nous avait déjà
donné une clé en fait pour résoudre en
partie du mystère
j'ai compris il ya peu de temps que moi
que mortimer en fait été physicien et
ceux qui nous ont aidés à résoudre en
fait une partie de l'énigme ce sont les
physiciens il ya plus de 50 ans en fait
jacobs avait déjà mis un physicien dans
le mystère de la grande pyramide est
donc souvent voilà quand on quand on
essaye de se reconnecter aux imaginaires
ya beaucoup de clés en fait qu'ils se
trouvent finalement dans la littérature
et dans un étang et dans ses oeuvres là
et donc les physiciens nous accompagner
dans cette aventure grâce à une
particule en fête magique qu'on appelle
le mieux alors s'ils ont des particules
cosmiques là pendant que je vous parle
tous les mètres carrés à la minute on a
à peu près 10 millions qui traversent
notre corps sont des particules
extrêmement chargée en énergie qui ont
une trajectoire rectiligne et qui vont
traverser la matière et au même titre
qu'on utilise les rayons x chez le
médecin on utilise des détecteurs de
muons pour faire des radiographies
pénétrante en fait de la de là
de la pyramide avec trois types de
dispositifs différents en muséographie
qui permettent donc de voir et donc
c'est grâce à ces millions qui sont
générés au niveau de l'atmosphère
le rayon cosmique tape l'atmosphère
terrestre à génère des des gerbes de
particules de protons des électrons et
ses fameux mur
l'enjeu est en fait d'avoir ensuite les
bons outils pour les capturer et les
analyser au sein de la au sein de la
pyramide est donc ce sont ces millions
qui nous ont permis de découvrir ce que
l'on a baptisé le scan pyramide big boys
donc aujourd'hui la mission menée 1-3
découvert qu'elle sait qu'on a un
couloir derrière la face nord on le voit
sans foncer sur cinq mètres il va sans
doute plus loin est-ce que ce couloir
est connecté aux beach boys on ne sait
toujours pas si le big boys et
horizontales ou incliné s'il est
constitué d'une ou plusieurs structures
mais ce qu'on a surtout appris c'est que
dans toute démarche d'innovation ce que
j'appelle le retour sur enthousiasme le
héros et précède toujours le retour sur
investissement est donc de cette mission
sont nés plusieurs innovations on a
avancé bien sur l'archéologie c'est ce
qui a intéressé le grand public avec la
découverte du big boys dans les
instruments de biographie en simulation
3d en robotique en réalité augmentée
c'était difficile d'emmener les gens sur
le terrain donc on s'est dit on va
plutôt à ramener l'egypte à paris donc
on a inventé des dispositifs qui
permettent de se balader à plusieurs
virtuellement dans la pyramide de khéops
et bientôt on cette expérience sera
disponible à la cité de l'architecturé à
paris
on a été obligé entre nous pour mieux
collaborer travailler imaginer des
outils de revue de projet collaborative
en réalité en réalité augmentée est en
ce moment même avec le cnrs et l'inria
on imagine ce que notre rêve ce serait
quand même bien sûr comme vous de
pénétrer dans cette pyramide de voir ce
qui se cache derrière le couleurs de la
face nord
on est en train d'inventer un robot
minimalement invasifs dont l'idée est
née lors d'un dîner avec françois dans
toute l'oeuvre de françois on ad on a
des dirigeables
on s'est dit pourquoi pas inventé un
système de dirigeable qui pourrait
rentrer dans un trou de trois
centimètres et demi et leurs nerfs et là
on en est à notre troisième troisième
prototype le retour sur enthousiasme le
plus important pour moi c'est quand j'ai
découvert qu'un prof de primaires en
angleterre avait donné pour devoir à ses
élèves d'imaginer le journal de bord en
fait delà de la mission scan pyramide
qu'il a postées en fait qu avait rédigé
ces enfants-là et
c'est peut-être qu'un de ces gamins
demain deviendra physiciens ou une
nouvelle compétence aujourd'hui qu'on ne
connaît pas encore et finira lui
peut-être pas résoudre le mystère de la
pyramide le plus important en fait c'est
le chemin qu'on a emprunté et donc dans
tous vides il y un trésor n'est pas
forcément celui qu'on croit
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]